Marisa is with us in California hi
Marisa how are you good how are you
talking you to your question for dr.
John well um here's just some background
info I recently been I'm married for two
years my first marriage my husband
second marriage we're on baby step two I
am 32 years old and he's 45 he has a
daughter who's a junior um so um you
know my concern is that looking at the
future he'll be maybe I don't know 63 by
the time we've already paid off her home
mortgage and and you know living and
giving like no one else and being
debt-free so um you know what would be
your advice because our my stepdaughter
will be you know was going to college
already in the next two years and like I
said we're only on baby step two right
now and we have 90 K in debt what's the
90km debt on ninety canes that is
nothing but revolving credit cards and
no car before I got the yeah before I
got married I paid off my student loans
on my car but this is before I was
introduced to David Ramsey
so I didn't follow the you know small
step two biggest that plan that I
absolutely love and it's working for us
now is all credit cards everything but
credit card debt and the wedding who do
you over the who do you over the wedding
for the wedding wheel about $12,000 no
to whom to a credit card oh so it's all
credit cards yes $19,000 a credit card
debt mm-hmm that's all no other that I
total total debt ninety came that you
including his car which he owns twenty
thousand ah
what's your household income one hundred
and thirty thousand years
all right and so how fast do you think
you're gonna pay off 90 are you both of
you on the game on this we are we just
finished SPU two weeks ago and they're
gonna be definitely two years you know I
I hope so because oh no no no hope is
bull
that's not we're talking better you
should have already run the calculation
a hundred and thirty thousand minus
forty five thousand you can live on
matter of fact that's kind of woodsy
fide you got to cut deeper than that
mmm-hmm forty five thousand times two is
ninety thousand yes we have ninety
thousand in bed I know divided by two
years is forty-five thousand a year your
debt free in two years and you should be
debt free in eighteen months
you should be debt free faster than that
and by the way when's the kid go to
school Oh two years mm-hm yeah we put
her in a state school or better than
that in a community college for the
first two years which is free or near
free in California depending on the
situation and then we get to where we
cashflow her school and by the way he's
not gonna be 63 when you pay off your
house he's only forty-five you should be
debt-free completely and everything Tom
he's 53 and that daughter's get a job
and start putting money ahead towards
college as well game on there we go be
part of the solution absolutely good and
good news we send you a copy of Anthony
O'Neill's number one best-selling book
debt-free degree to help you get this
kid through school debt-free but you
should be able to make it
you just got to lean in on this really
hard